welcome
everyone thank you for joining us for
our presentation titled
the role of senior sequencing and
fragment analysis
by capillary electrophoresis in sars ko
v2 research
it is my pleasure to introduce you to dr
stephen williams
who is the r d leader for the capillary
electrophoresis business
at thermo fisher scientific in his role
dr williams has used his extend
extensive experience in developing and
commercializing capillary
electrophoresis
instrumentation and application
applications
related to genetic analysis for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the tab at the very top of your
screen
if any questions arise during this
presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the q
a box
our speaker will address your questions
following his presentation
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and thus offers free edu
continuing education credits and you can
click on the continuing education
credits
tab located at the top right corner of
the presentation window
and follow that process to obtain your
credits
please join me now in welcoming dr
williams i will now
turn the presentation over to him
hi uh thanks for joining me today i'm
steve williams and i lead the capillary
electrophoresis r d
group within the genetic sciences
division um at thermal fissure
scientific
and today i'd like to highlight the role
of sanger sequencing and fragment
analysis in the study
of sar cov2
so by a way of introduction and reminder
there are two different genetic analysis
applications that run on the family of
applied biosystems
and capillary electrophoresis systems
the first is
sanger sequencing using big diterminated
chemistry
which is used to carry out standard dna
sequencing
such as lenovo sequencing targeted
re-sequencing
variant detection and plasmid sequencing
and the second is
fragment analysis which uses
fluorescently labeled primers
to amplify specific regions of a target
dna
to produce fragments of specific size
and this has a wide range of application
including quantitative fluorescence pcr
microsatellite analysis str analysis for
human identification forensic
applications and
snip genotyping thermofisher has a
suite of ce genetic analyzers that are
designed to meet the throughput needs of
users
so we have a high throughput system the
3730 which has 96 capillaries
and integrated plate loader we have a
medium throughput system the 3500
xl which is either a
8 capillary system or a 24 capillary
system
and also exists as a us ibd and ceibd
approved system
and then we have the latest addition to
our
instrument portfolio which is the seek
studio
system uh which is a benchtop instrument
very easy to use in this for capillary
system and during today's presentation
i'll i'll discuss how sangre sequencing
and
fragment analysis in the can be used in
the study of
cov2 and i'll talk about various
published articles
as well as in-house work during the
presentation and give acknowledgement
where appropriate via citation to the
authors of those
articles
so first brief introduction to
coronaviruses and the impact that they
have had on
human health so i think as everybody
knows at this point in time
um the coronaviruses are named for the
crown-like spikes on their surface
and there are four main subgroups or
genera of coronaviruses these are alpha
beta
gamma and delta and coronaviruses
human coronary viruses were first
identified in the mid-1960s
and there are seven uh coronaviruses
that can infect humans
um the first four in this list the 229e
and l63 and oc43 and hku1
and these all produce fairly mild
symptoms
and symptoms of a common cold in humans
and then there are three more serious
viruses that produce much more severe
respiratory infections
and these are the middle east
respiratory syndrome or mers
and then the first version of sars
and then the version of sars that we're
dealing with now
which is the virus that causes covid19
and these coronaviruses can affect
animals and can evolve and then infect
humans through this
zoonosis process so
back in 2003 sars acute respiratory
syndrome sarah cov the first version of
sars
was identified in china in 2003
2000 2002 2003. it's killed you know
nearly 650 people
in china and hong kong and it's thought
to have been
transmitted to humans uh
via bats and then into spits and then on
into humans
and 2012 was the
the normal mirrors and this was
identified in saudi arabia in 2012
um and killed over 800 people in the
middle east
and was transferred from dromedary
camels into humans
and now we're dealing with the latest
strain of uh
sarah sarcio v2 uh first identified at
the end of 2019
in china and wuhan china and to date
has affected approximately 30 million
people around the world i think we just
passed the 30 million mark
the other day and we have close to 1
million deaths globally
and virus is thought to be a market
um in juan and it's not currently known
uh the um the animal host
for the sparta but it's thought to be
bats again possibly being transferred
from bats to pangolins but that
remains to be determined and the
original source of the virus can take
quite a while
to determine in the case of uh the first
version of sas it took i think over a
decade
to verify the transmission realm
so since the first whole genome of sara
cov2 was published back in
in mid-january scientists have sequenced
tens of thousands of virus genomes
and this information has been really
valuable for studying pathogen evolution
and an academic spread so the the next
strain database is the main global
repository for all of these sequences
and tens of thousands of sequences are
now available so
ngs has of course been the primary
technology used for whole genome
sequencing
and there are many different uh
published protocols on different ngs
platforms that are
available including the iron seek
sara covt research panel which provides
any of the viral genome
and when it runs on the genexis
integrated sequencer
has a turnaround time of about one day
to produce a full viral sequence
so for many of the ngs protocols sanger
sequencing
plays a role to help gap fill ngs
sequences
and to confirm identified variants in
fact some of the
very early sequencing data from groups
in china use sanger sequencing to gap
fill the
original ngs data but in addition to
that there are two published protocols
for
complete genome sequencing of the sarco
v2 virus
one from the cdc in in the us and
another from the
cdc in china
so the first uh genome sanger sequencing
protocol was published by cdc back in
march
um shortly after the first
sequence of the virus was published um
the workflow is shown in the top of this
slide
it begins with rna extraction and then
an tp
in the case of samples that have
so typically these are ct values of 27
and above would require this second pcr
step
um pcr products are purified
via an exosapi purification and then a
cycle sequencing
cycle sequence using that big day
terminator version
3.1 sequencing protocol and then
separated
on the 3730 capillary electrophoresis
instrument
and for the cdc protocol there are 38
primer pairs that are needed to span
the nearly 30 000 bases of the virus and
these are tiled across the virus as
shown in the top of the slide
and in the cases of low viral load where
a second round nested pcr
is performed primers that sit just
inside the original primers are used
and this produces amplicons in the range
of about 320 to 1000 base pairs
and then four individual sequencing
reactions are used to sequence both the
forward and the reverse regions of
each pcr product so a total of 148
sequencing primers are used
and a single sample takes about 18 hours
to sequence
via this approach um and as i mentioned
the
this this protocol is very useful for
detecting
low viral load samples so the second
published protocol
shown in the bottom of the slide is very
similar approach um it tiles
and amplicons across the genome
in this case also 38 prime of paris are
used uh producing amplicons in the range
of 600 to 1400 base pairs in length
a difference being here is that a rapid
amplification of cd
cdna and n's race approaches
used to sequence the um the three prime
and the five prime end of the virus
um so there are a number of sanger
sequence full genomes in the
in the next strain database particularly
from regions where access to expensive
ngs instrumentation and expertise is
limited
and also for samples that
are very low viral loads saying or
sequencing is often the preferred choice
so beyond sangra beyond sequencing the
entire genome
sanger also has a significant role to
help understand the host response to the
virus
um the life cycle of sarcob2 infection
begins
with the entry of the virus into the
cell through the h2 receptor that's
shown in the top
left of the slide and the swipe region
of the virus binds to ace2 through the
receptor binding domain of the virus
variation in the h2 receptor sequence
can
affect how tightly the virus binds um
it might alter host susceptibility to
sire cov2 infection
and be responsible for person-to-person
differences that are seen in the
infection
so studies have shown that there are
about 120 amino acids
on the outside of the outer surface of
h2 that span the interface of the
receptor binding domain of the virus and
there are two key hotspot mutations
um here in the alpha helical bundle
and these are important for sar cov2
binding and these are lysine 31 and
lysine 353
and sanger sequencing can be used to
identify different variants
in this region so antibodies
from vaccination or as a result of
infection
um target the receptive binding domain
of the spike protein they neutralize the
virus
by binding in this region and block
entry to the cell
so therapeutic neutralizing antibodies
you know also target this region a spike
protein
and there's somewhere on the order of
about 20 different monoclonal antibodies
um that are that are currently in
clinical trials
as treatment options for the infection
with coronavirus and there are many more
that are in pre-clinical development as
well
so although mutation rates of the virus
are slow
some changes in the receptor binding
domain have been seen in some isolates
and it remains important to monitor uh
the virus for changes um of sequence in
the receptor binding domain
sumane is about 183 amino acids and so
it can easily be sequenced by
sanger sequencing and there's no need to
sequence the entire virus for this
purpose
so after the virus has entered the cell
newly formed virus is ingested by
antigen presenting cells that's shown in
the diagram which go on
to display fragments of the virus and
can activate
t helper cells which then go on to turn
on b
cells which produce um antibodies
um against the virus or to activate
cytotoxic t cells which can destroy the
virus
um so b cells can be isolated from
patients infected with the virus by
using the
spike protein as bait
and then a technique like flow cytometry
to isolate
individual b cells and there are
well-established protocols for saying a
sequencing of heavy chain
and light chain regions of antibodies
and that have been recovered from b
cells so this is really useful for
identifying type binding antibody
sequences
um
finally as we begin to think ahead to
the prospect
of an effective coronavirus vaccine next
year
the question of durability of response
in an individual
is an important question um and there's
a growing
body of research that links immune
response to
variations in the microbiome composition
present in our bodies so
there are many there are as many as 100
times more bacterial genes residing in
humans than
human genes and recent data indicates
that gut microbiota can modulate the
response to vaccines
and as we'll see in the next few slides
a fragment analysis basic
approach can provide a rapid
cost-effective approach to
profiling microbiota in the gut and the
airways
so a technique uh known as iso
is pro has been developed by a small
startup company in the netherlands
called in biome
um and their approach is based on the
specific amplification of interspace
regions in bacteria
to generate fluorescently labeled
fragments that can then be separated
on applied biosystems genetic analyzer
instruments so all bacteria
have at least one in the space region
and men and many bacteria have multiple
regions
and is pro relies on length and sequence
polymorphisms
of these interspace regions to provide
identification of the bacteria
so for example in the bottom of this
slide show a
these interspace regions for this
particular
bacterial species enterococcus basalis
it has four different interspace regions
is one is two ice iii and is4
when uh after amplification of is1 and
is2 you get a
377 base base pair fragment
um and amplification of is3 and is4
produces
275 base pair fragment and so each
bacteria has
an almost unique fingerprint uh when
these interspace regions
um are amplified and you can also
group different phylum of bacteria um
in by using different labeled
primers so uh three different colors
shown here for three different file
and some of the advantages of this
approach um
are that it's a rapid workflow you can
get an answer within about a four to
five hour turnaround time
does not require culture of the bacteria
and it can detect unknown and unknown
species
no need to predefine the species that
you're looking for
um and in addition um it
can detect bacterial bacteria that
cannot be cultivated so our colleagues
in biome have used this approach to
examine
microbiota and nasal pharyngeal swabs
collected from patients the
individuals that have been infected with
osiris-cov2
and they have used this technique to
identify
specific microbiota profiles that may be
correlated to the likelihood of
infection of the virus
they examined 135 different clinical
research samples from people ranging
in age from the very young to the very
elderly in this zero to 100 age
range and they
use the ios pro assay to profile dna
isolated from these nasopharyngeal fraud
so what you can see
on the slide is a resulting claustrogram
where the pcr status of each individual
is listed either as red or green red
being positive for the virus green being
negative for the virus
and these were independently determined
by qpcr
um and then you can you can see that um
after unsupervised clustering was
performed of all of the profiles there's
a clear
profile of the 77 samples with similar
microbiota uh profile in the center of
the
uh the cluster gram here um
and in addition
well um so this cluster of
um this central cluster showed a
very low level or a relatively low level
of co2 positivity compared to the
cluster
that was outside of the um
of the central cluster so in the for the
cluster about 25 percent of the
people were cov2 a positive and outside
of this cluster this rose to 47 percent
and in addition um
data that's not shown in the slide
indicates that older individuals were
actually enriched for this
h signature which poses the question
whether there is an age-dependent
pharyngeal microbiota signature
that has an increased susceptibility so
further and more detailed analysis that
this data set can be
found in this publication that's listed
on the slide
or alternatively there is a poster that
will also be presented in this
conference that
goes into more detail into the data
analysis and the conclusions
so i want to switch gears now and talk
a little bit about the use of sanger
let's do an article um because wide
recognition demonic disease is a growing
threat in fact the cdc estimates that
more than
every 10 people can be spread from
animals
and in fact three out of four new or
emerging infectious diseases actually
uh animals into people and they can we
can pass
um either directly um from an animal
into a human for example if we discuss
um andromedas uh we're responsible
for directly transferring the mers virus
um and of course we have a bird flu and
swine flu that can be directly
transferred into humans
or um they can start from a viral source
such as a bat and pass through
um another animal either a civet as in
the case of
original sars or it's postulated that
the pangolins are the intermediary
uh hosts for the sarcov2 virus
so there's a growing need for assays
that can detect pathogens
that can pass from humans to animals to
humans
and also to identify the natural
reservoir for a particular pathogen that
has
the possibility of infecting human
population
so sequencing can be used to address
this
to provide information on pathogens in
animal and animal hosts that are
closely related to humanized versions
and more likely to cross the
species boundary so one
approach that has been used for this
purpose
that is has capability to
identify all currently recognized and
potentially future
emergent coronaviruses is an rt-pcr
amplification based approach
followed by sequencing of a particular
region of the coronavirus this
rna-dependent
rna polymerase region of the virus in
the orth
b region and this approach is described
in the publication listed at the top of
the slide here in the journal of
clinical
virology but has been widely used by
others as well
the approach consists of two different
pcrs that use degenerate primers
a first pcr that produces
an amplicon about 670 bases in length
with degenerate forward and reverse
primers and then a second pcr
that is a nested approach that generates
a smaller fragment
again using a degenerate primer of about
600 base pairs and this
amplicon can then be sanger sequenced
to confirm the identity so with this
approach you know there are a large
number of coronaviruses that can be
identified
um and the assay shows uh
virtually no cross-reactivity with other
common respiratory pathogens such as
rsb or flu and it can be used
to routinely screen uh individuals
whose occupation bring them into close
contact with animals
for prolonged periods of time or it can
be used for
routine surveillance in species such as
bats
which are reservoirs for viruses with
human pathogenic potential
so finally i'd like to briefly describe
an application
of ce and the study of sara cov to
detection that is based on a fragment
analysis approach
the workflow for ce fragment analysis
detection is actually similar to qpcr it
starts with a collection of the sample
in a via nasopharyngeal swab and then
extraction
of the rna for example using
one of the kits from thermo fissure a
magmax viral pathogen nucleic acid
isolation kit and then after rna
extraction
an rt pcr step is performed with
fluorescently
labeled primers and at the end of this
the
fragments recently labeled fragments
that have been amplified
are identified on the ce
and the size of the fragment and the
color of the fragment
encodes data about which amplicon is
being detected
and the data can be analyzed via a
software such as a
g-matter from thermo-fisher so for the
assay developed at thermo-fissure there
were three different regions of the
virus that were amplified
one from the off 1ab region the second
from the spike
gene and the third from the nuclear
capsule gene and this results in three
different size fragments
an n protein fragment at 396 base pairs
and off 1ab
425 and s protein at 437 base pairs
and additionally an rna positive control
is added
to the reaction and to help check for
the presence of
any uh pcr inhibitors that might prevent
amplification
so one added feature of this assay that
i'd like to point out
is the use of multiple fluorescently
labeled primers
this allows after amplification for the
samples to be combined to be pooled
together
such that four individual reactions can
be run
on the capillary combined and read out
and run on the ce
and the fragments are then identified
based on not only the size but also the
color so
each capillary can then produce answers
for for the application from four
individuals
and the sensitivity of this approach is
is similar to qpcr methods
and more details on the protocol
and an application note can be found on
the thermofisher website as shown on the
slide
including the sequences of all of the
primers
that are used in the assay
so um by way of summary um
what i've hopefully what i've shown you
is that sanger sequencing and fragment
analysis technologies
are widely useful in the detection and
sequencing of sars cov2
sangro sequencing can be used to support
an ngs
whole genome sequencing by a gap filling
and confirmation of variants but can
also be used
to generate a whole genome sequence
by itself targeted sequencing you know
can be used
to look at cyber cov2 host response
factors such as
a sequence of h2 receptors
which the virus binds to to gain entry
to the cell or can be used to
look at the immune response
look at the antibody sequences that are
produced from individual
b cells by sequencing of the variable
regions
um there has been an assay developed
that amplifies and sequences a highly
conserved region
of the virus the rdpr rprp region
and this can be useful to identify the
natural reservoir of the virus or to
help track
animal coronaviruses that may jump to
species
and then finally bacterial profiling
using the is pro technology
can develop a more comprehensive
understanding of how the microbiome can
influence host response to pathogen
infection
so with that i i'll conclude my talk and
invite any questions and thank you for
your time
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
sorry i believe you couldn't hear me
that's yes i can hear you now thank you
my bad thank you so i was just saying
thank you dr williams for your
outstanding presentation and we'll now
move into the live
q a portion of this presentation um and
as a reminder please submit your
questions
to the q a box so our first question
again
it says sorry i may have missed this in
your talk when would i use stranger
sequencing as the primary sequencing
method
for sars cov2 yeah great question thanks
for that
i think there are a couple of
circumstances under which you might
consider using sanger sequencing
um obviously you know it's not suitable
for sequencing large numbers of virus
or viral samples but um for individual
viral samples
it is possibility since the genome is 30
000 bases and that's accessible
uh via the sanger method it takes about
you know about a day
to sequence a single virus and that
obviously scales linearly so if you need
to sequence more
it will take corresponding number of
days
but for single samples i think sanger is
an option i think the second place
where it's an option is for low viral
load
sanger is a quite a sensitive technique
um it's possible to go down
to um you know sort of 10 copy range
and obtain good sequencing and data
and of course ngs does struggle a little
bit
at the low copy number in getting a
really good coverage
in fact recently i saw a publication
where they had used sanger sequencing
for sequencing the virus
that had been isolated from the air
ducts in in hospitals
and in that case the the viral the
levels of the virus were very low and
sanger sequencing
uh proved very effective um in
determining
the uh the complete genome sequence of
the virus in that case so
for single samples sanger is useful and
then also for
samples that have low viral load i think
those are the two primary usages
wonderful and i do have one more
question for you if we can answer it
quickly
um if you would like to run both
sequencing and fragment analysis can
this be done on the same interest
instrument at the same time
um it can be done on the same instrument
so within a plate
you can run sanger sequencing and
fragment analysis
it can't be done within the same run so
one particular ce run would be dedicated
either towards a saying or sequencing or
fragment analysis but
back to back runs could be done using
with the same instrument
[Music]
on both technologies can run on the same
instrument yes
wonderful thank you so much again dr
williams and thank you for the audience
for your questions
dr williams will be moving to the expert
lounge right after this talk
um to continue discussing his
presentation and answering questions
submitted during
this presentation and this presentation
will be available on demand
of next year 2021 so please share it
with a colleague
who might be interested in today's topic
and you can visit the agenda tab in the
auditorium for a full listing
thank you so much again and um for your
participation and thank you dr williams
see you in the expert lounge goodbye
everybody